c'est aujourd'hui la journée mondiale
contre le travail des enfants 168
millions d'enfants dans le monde sont
encore forcé au travail ou à l'
esclavage carrément parfois vous le
savez au pl de leur vie alors le sort de
ces petits retoucher des élèves d'une
école de la prairie qui essaie de
changer le monde
un bracelet à la fois ce fut lent ledit
matin si le début des examens pour les
élèves de l'école secondaire la
magdeleine sauf pour une trentaine de
jeunes du programme international eux
sont en classe pour présenter leur
projet les bracelets de l'espoir elle
serait le fun quand même même si vous
faites vos petits bracelets que vous
regardiez ses élèves de deuxième
secondaire ont fabriqué et vendu près de
2000 bracelet le but amasser des fonds
pour une petite ong qui sont des enfants
de l' esclavage on aime les petits
bracelets qui font les élèves eux mêmes
le patio des brassées d'amitié c'est que
je me disais ça serait comme un geste
d'amitié envers ses enfants le travail
que mes élèves qui sont très choyé
puisse participer pour changer pour
changer le monde
les élèves ont visionné des reportages
sur des enfants qui travaillent dans des
mines au pakistan dans des plantations
de cacao en côte d'ivoire il ya là comme
ds insecticides pour empêcher de nuire à
la production
c'est un enfant qui faisait ça mais ce
n'est ce pas dangereux tue pas toxique
est pour ceux qui marquent
topi sont plus vraiment santé et ça
m'attriste parce que moi j'ai des frères
plus jeune plus je m'imagine que c'est
eux qui sont obligés de travailler comme
ça au lieu d'aller à l'école puis je
trouve que l'école c'est important
dans leurs cours d'anglais les élèves
ont développé des outils de
sensibilisation
ce vidéo clip et une page facebook ça
sensibilise les gens parce qu'on a vu
exactement qu'est ce qui se passe dans
le monde
c'est donc ce soir que ça les six déjà
posé les petits gestes que l'on fait de
nous autres cibles ils ont aussi envoyé
des lettres aux premiers ministres du
canada et à des entreprises soupçonné
d'acheter des billets du matériel
produit par des enfants juste les
chandails comporte la vie fournissant un
exemple c'est du coton fait par les
enfants
et surprise vraiment que des compagnies
accès des employés des enfants en bas
âge comme ceux ont fait tout le temps
que tout coûte moins cher aux tanks que
tout soit meilleur puis je pense que
c'est à cause de ça aussi qu'il continue
à employer des enfants comme ça
ces jeunes se disent prêts à réduire de
moitié leur garde-robe à payer leurs
chocolats plus cher si cela peut changer
le monde
on pourrait peut-être changer le monde
petit à petit mais c'est vrai que ça va
prendre beaucoup beaucoup de temps et il
faudra beaucoup d'argent on réussit
rarement à ramasser un gros total c'est
qui peut à aider à ouvrir de nouvelles
écoles dans les pays des pauvretés
les jeux m'ont tabassé 4200 dollars cela
aidera scolarisés pendant un an
25 enfants qui travaillait avant dans
une décharge en inde
ici sophie langlois radio-canada à la
prairie